donovan sanchez having a rough year for
the gnats this year can be summed up in
his first inning as era
in the first innings 9.90 sanchez
delivers swinging a ground ball right
side garcia toward the whole edge of the
outfield grass and the short throw to
brock holt from there in time for the
out nemo retired swinging a slow roller
up the first base line holt will feel
and go right to the bag with the right
foot ahead of mcneil getting there two
out nobody on here at the top of the
first inning swinging a ground ball
again pull to the first baseman holt
he'll flip it to sanchez they're
covering in time for the out of the side
retired well porcello's last start was
his best 7 innings 10 strikeouts only
one run allowed in his last start didn't
get the win andrew stevenson to lead off
and open up the third base line of
beauty by andrew stevenson they'll let
it roll it'll come to a stop on the
grass and he has himself a lead off bunt
single an 11-game hitting streak for
andrew stevenson now 13 for his last 29
with that bunt single and that was a
dandy here's trey turner a little half
swing shallow right in comes nimmo to
retire turner one out and juan soto
coming up that's driven out to center
field chasing horadia back and he makes
the catch guillermo herrera got a nice
jump on that ball going away yadiel
hernandez swung on and missed strike
three got him with a change up that
retires the side now trey turner still
looking for his first hit in this series
swinging a fly ball well hit right
center field toward the gap nimmo
chasing's not going to get it this one
is gone hits the top of the fence and
goes over trey turner with a line drive
home run nationals in front one to
nothing so soto is in scoring position
for yadiel hernandez swing a line drive
base hit right field down the line
headed to the corner this is going to be
extra bases soto will score so it's an
rbi double for yada yall hernandez and
the nationals lead it two to nothing
here's kurt suzuki he's lined up the
middle and a base hit over the leaping
shortstop rosario and hernandez will
score suzuki will hold it first and the
nationals lead the mets three to nothing
the batter now is harrison the eighth
man to bat in the inning swing a little
looping fly ball to shallow right nimmo
chasing this and he's not going to get
it it dunks in for a hit suzuki will
score and the nationals lead at four to
nothing so here's taylor the ninth man
to bat in the inning and he swings and
rolls one left side and sprawling stop
rosario edge of the outfield grass he'll
make no throw and it's an rbi infield
hit for michael taylor and the nationals
lead five to nothing canoe will stride
towards second it's a one out double his
pitch to alonso that's hitting the air
toward left center field this one's
headed for the gap and that ball is gone
a home run a line drive home run by
alonso into the bullpen what a shot and
the mets get two runs back it's now five
to two zombie rosario leads off the
fifth against anabol sanchez swinging a
chopper left side moving it over to his
right turner throws on the run to hold
it first and gets him by a half step
turner makes a smooth play to retire
rosario for out number one swinging a
long drive to left sending stevenson on
the run back to the warning track near
the fence he's there and he makes the
catch as he kisses up against the wall
with his left shoulder pitch hit on the
ground to third it's backhanded deep at
third by harrison the long long throw is
right on target and sanchez has himself
a six pitch inning well for the first
time in nearly a month dylan potanzis
will take the mound for the mets so two
walks in the inning and now stevenson
will bat two two breaking ball on the
outside corner strike three called so
potanzas works a scoreless inning two
walks two strikeouts for no hits sanchez
will try to keep this rolling for as
long as he can brandon nimmo will start
the sixth there's ball four and so
nemo's on with the walk sanchez delivers
swinging a ground ball to first charging
in is holy throws to second one harrison
back to first not in time with sanchez
the pitcher covering good try
good play by hope they cut down the lead
runner one man away in robinson canoe
coming up canoe bounces one up the
middle it's going to sneak on through a
base hit into center field
stopping at second is mcneil and cano
with the second hit of the game
davey martinez is out of the dugout
on his way to the mound
mall sanchez the relatively low pitch
count but again the sixth inning is
like the eighth inning
it looks like davey is going to make a
change
and what would end the season for anibal
sanchez
and it will wander sure will be coming
in and so with runners at first and
second one out pete alonso will come to
the plate representing the potential
tying run 3-2 coming and alonso takes
outside ball four and the bases are
loaded and now the base is loaded with
one out and todd frazier coming up tying
runs on base
and he drills that one into left field
for a base hit that'll bring in mcneal
frazier with an rbi single to get the
mets closer and it's now five to three
washington so the bases remain loaded
here's guillermo swing and a miss he
struck him out with a cutter for out
number two that's big for sure and now
ahmed rosario will be the hitter did he
go after it on a high cutter he did says
joe west on the appeal at first the
inning is over
swero gets two strikeouts so here's
daniel hudson making his first
appearance of this series now the mets
are down to their final out and a drive
to right
juan soto is there
and he reaches up at the last minute to
pull it in and they sweep the
double-header from the mets
[Music]